bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa dj ci siamo subito senso
ditelo che siete tutti eccitati dopo
questa mia pronuncia english ronca
ragazzi è vero che i giochi moderni sono
veramente facili nel senso che ti
aiutano a fare qualsiasi cosa diciamo
quindi sono molto più semplici ma
addirittura farti vedere che per
cliccare play bisogna premere il tasto
sinistro mi sembra eccessivo grazie che
me l'hai detto veramente sei la mia luce
anche ragazzi siamo su hansel e gretel
93 ansa il contrario è che faccio a mi
posso muovere per prendere cose sì ma
sembra un rincoglionito mi era piaciuto
un casino il primo che ho fatto cos'è lo
prendo ha già le ma le monete devo
prenderne almeno 10 sono cose non devo
tirarlo tirar fuori così facendo al
search ghiaccio ci fai lì sotto cosa
cerchi la alle talpe salve ma perché c'è
gente sotto terra un già salve va detto
sei un nuovo sedile cottage
ecco bravo tira tira
[Musica]
ok ragazzi perché sono appena esplose
due teche bel gioco per bambini a salve
ascolti e di ance un corvo
no no no no non usare quella roba che
amano perfetto a era un sogno
minchia meno male non sognava siamo
ripartiti dov'eravamo rimasti
si è capito bene ragazzi era era tutta
una mera era un sogno
siamo ripartiti esattamente là dove ci
eravamo fermati con hansel e gretel 1
bene o male perché si sta mettendo
leggermente ma le assicuro non è
violento sto gioco proprio no insieme di
merda ti svegli io continuerò a
bacchettarlo per il resto della mia vita
finché non comunque ragazzi il primo
episodio ha finito che ci stavano
inseguendo è siamo arrivati fino qua ho
trovato era cos'è trovato un disegno che
cosa cosa mi servono dice così facendo
cosa mi serve sta roba beh ho trovato
una coscia di pollo quante volte vi è
capitato ragazzi di trovare cosce di
pollo in un albero dai la coscia di
pollo adams è perfetto così si sveglia
ad ora so quanta zio temi questo ficcate
la tu sei dove ecco bravo
no non intendevo proprio quello sguardo
sveglio che c'è a mio fratello scorta sa
già che lo posso picchiare poi lui si fa
male tipo così non piace una freccia che
indica destra quindi credo che io debba
andare ecco perfetto
cosa fai a non far cazzate io vado
avanti tu rimani lì a sorvegliarli c'è
una trappola qua lo sa e lo sapevo anche
perché ci sono andato sopra che è
successo così era qualcosa che è
successo ma giorno
salve ascolta aceh intrappolati lei è un
figo cioè intrappolati questo tizio
sentiti ha anche picchiato in facciano
bene a lui e lei è morta proprio e lui è
meglio se fosse morto che devo decidere
io che cosa facciamo col piede che è
commestibile è un'ordinazione proprio il
menù che bel ristorante è c'è
tripadvisor non seriamente non ho capito
cosa devo fare
vi parlo e tu ci dai una mano per favore
devo mangiare se mangio rosso roba
diventa un albero cioè di vento che
schifo guardie ma mi sembra un po troppo
al sangue e melo qua c'è un po di più
per favore va beh io io io andrei sul no
perché no guarda e mi dispiace
il cuoco l'ordine che è successo i cazzi
a cosa stai facendo ne crea la portata
indietro ha funzionato sta cosa del
cuore secondo me li fa un cazziatone
così cuoco perché la cucinato malissimo
amico mio ti è spuntato un corno ragazzi
non siamo ho preso il vino al vino io
continua a bere vino a caso vite non
esplodo ministro ti manda a portare
delle cose ma basta no io io io non lo
mangio ok ma vedrai mangiamo la pazienza
che buono
che bello ma questo non è un gioco per
bambini
ascoltami albero con la pipa con la pipa
che ti dona una pipe ragazzi ho io sto
continuando a dire no però vabbè merda
mi sa che è finito male lui la torta la
tua è la forza la mangio dai la torta la
maggio la mangiando a lato
la torta la devo mangiare forza mista
ragazzi è il mio compleanno tra l'altro
grazie
amy mi faceva un po schifo e sono morto
è l'ora 7 stronzi non so se funziona
ragazzi mamma ci prova se bevo sta roba
e gli sputi in faccia
pam e ciò non mio dio è andato a fuoco
liberati col coltello vai così vai forza
ragazzi james bond una roba già possa
andare affanculo adesso mi dispiace però
ti lascia la torta che buono non so se
andare di qua perché c'è il tizio di
qualche veti della gente che c'è in
questo gioco mi piace questo gioco
veramente mi è andato a fuoco è morto
la cresta corra un bravo stacca di un
braccio lurido per cento eccolo qua il
braccio e mio ragazzi sono sono malvagio
mi dispiace e musso picchiare questo
coso bellissimo nalesso torna di replica
tutti i tre mentre ragazzi son riusciti
a salvarmi non chiedetemi cosa è caduto
è caduto un libro bello e mi piace
questo libro che figura si è esattamente
la mia faccia quando guardavo il libro
di matematica uguale scalda zio mi sta
simpatico to sul soffitto però mi mi
dispiace aveva perfetta andiamo ragazzi
è leggermente più violento questo gioco
vicolo precedente però c'è una trappola
qua e se ci vado sopra amica torna a
devo mettere una carota perfetto non c'e
la lega ma dove hansel dove cazzo andato
a mio fratello una trappola di una
moneta in una trappola se ci vado sopra
muoio futuro è così ma dall antica vabbè
ma non è un po esagerato amico mio io
ragazzi sono due ore che sono in giro
senza trovare mio fratello non ha idea
di dove sia finito però è una cosa che
quella roba sull'ad non mi interessa
trovato la moneta 22 fatato ragazzi ho
perso il ramo non ce l'ho più ram
ascolti e bella donna le dispiace se non
posso neanche passare di qua che devo
fare
non posso neanche passarci torni
indietro bello però non ho capito chi
era gratis e ma va bene uno di qualche e
meglio è bello comunque fantastico fino
ad un orso che blocca lastra mica tipo
snor l'acs state poche flauto quassù a
miss brana vivono però lo faccio perchè
sono bello ma che bello questo motivo
che bella espressione a michele va beh
queste così si stringe amicizia in casa
fa vi devo portare lo strappo l'ape
rossi dall'orso è già ovvio è che sto
albero sembra che abbia il buco del culo
vabbè non ho capito però c'è una rana
c'era una rana è sparita per orsi eccoci
qua ci sia ragazzi la sposto se riesco
per come faccio ho preso la rana ragazzi
però non ha capito che mi secco no no ti
prendi mica mi dispiace non volevo la
trappola è scattata così l'ho presa per
adesso dobbiamo andare dalla merda di
coda sì l'ho presa e ma non cade sono un
cazzo salve è un mio dio maniaco che
cos'è perché c'è un mani aprendo la
carota se non ti dispiace grazie è molto
gentile così arrivare ecco il coniglio
che sta dietro l'albero e lo
intrappolano se vado sì sì
il coni e brandy lo prendi e veloce
serve è morto grazie ho preso delle cose
di coniglio amico orsacchiotto se ti
faccio vedere questo regalino bello o
cancellò come faccio è perfetto ragazzi
stiamo per assistere a un suicidio credo
o al costo di coniglio quindi posso
metterlo quasi perfetto ossa di merda
vieni qua ecco bravo bravo bravo è il
miur settino come fa red bull po meno
tutto con creazzo solo accanto alla
parte dopo anche una moneta fantastico
devo capire come arrivare a prendere 10
monete per comprarmi la palla però
impossibile sta roba
prendi cos'è sacco di mercy mi chiama e
mancano 2
che bello c'è una mano lo ridà mano cosa
non ha ben capito sta cosa del dito
medio però vabbè comunque devo capire
ancora un attimo che palle ma cos'è ma
che è sta roba fermi un attimo a cenare
cazzo si è chiusa bene ragazzi c'è un
tizio o mio dio se ne ha il tizio sono
andato una ragazza cosa fighissimo poi e
poi e poi lei lo saluta dalla finestra
perfetto e boe e che è successo poi lui
è tornato ubriaco e dovendo quale pub di
preciso apri la porta lo leggo come cosa
ho fatto a ubrica l'ha picchiata l'ha
uccisa con l'ascia ma perché vabbè mi
odierno questa cosa più credibile che
abbia mai visto che in un gioco flash o
la madonna ma che schifo oscar che sono
così violenti tanto lei sta godendo la
scena di brutto la s cosa cazzo appena
mendes è addormentata le lascia già vero
minchia meno dimenticato perfetto fra un
fantastico ragazzo sono solo un genio
era troppa roba posso pensare adesso c'è
una tomba una bella top perfetto che beh
è proprio allegro questo posto posso
andare di qua che prima non ci sono
andato a sell
ecco trovata ecco cosa stai facendo chi
sono quei tizi perché di giocare con le
fatine che ti uccidono la famiglia
ragazzi alla fatina che cos'è prendi la
prendo
vai giorno ma che bello che sono certi
tocchi mi ha preso la faccia è morto
sono senza faccia adesso sono diventato
slider mentre gara una senza ansie sen
deficiente sono senza eco bravate si è
accorta staff ha immaginato in adesso
devi aiutare il tuo è come faccio ma
dove vai ma cosa no non dirmi che sono
anzi ti prego guarda ragazzi concluso fu
il primo episodio di gretel e ansia
perché questo è veramente violento
rispetto a prima veramente tanto
continuo le prossime ha bisogno di
ragazzi come al solito servito è
piaciuto lasciato commento mi piace
anche poi cenni facebook e come non
divide ho trovato nella descrizione cioè
se volessi di scrittrici viggiano
prossimo
belle ragazze